howdy Mordechai Rubenstein here with GQ
today talking about tuxedos classic tux
tuxedo black-tie formal it's all about
the fit you could have the cheapest
tuxedo rental you can have your
grandfather's you could have a
secondhand you could have it entail 'red
you could have it made for you if it's
ill-fitting and by that I mean the
shoulders exaggerated swimming in the
jacket you can barely button it open the
camping buttoned it all no good
no but the sleeve length sure you want
to show a bit of cuff there's rules
eighth of an inch quarter of an inch
power leak air it's not about this it's
just about a hair it's just about you
know it doesn't matter if it's French
cuff or a normal button it doesn't
matter if it's a turn up I don't want to
see your giant cuff links I'm not seeing
as many cumberbund lately and I think
that's a great way to wear a tuxedo open
whether you're skinny or fat I think
it's kind of cool because it acts as a
belt to garter keeping you in at the
same time it's refreshing so you don't
see the like you know the wrinkled shirt
coming out of the waistband entry level
tuxedo doesn't have to be designer
doesn't have to be high-fashion in fact
I think it shouldn't I think it should
be training wheels I think it should be
cheap off the rack ready to go size to
fit and what I mean by that is not
hugging the tushy and not hugging the
pits you got to be able to move you got
to be able to hail the cab you got to be
able to like conduct the choir and stuff
you know you got you got to move with
ease if it's a little bit big that's
okay I think the trouser should meet the
back of the shoe heel we don't see that
today today we see crop cropped and more
cropped I mean it shouldn't be hugging
your your body I'm not sure that they
can move in these body hugging pants you
could staple the hem for all I care but
just have it the right length
hopefully the staples are black
I love a one-button tux I love a
two-button tux I don't know that it
needs more than that unless it's
double-breasted I love a peak lapel tux
I love a notch lapel tux depending on
the body frame how much does the lapel
need to be peaking I don't know you know
that's it's up to the body type white
shirt classic but sometimes a black
shirt with a tuxedo you can wear a black
t-shirt with exceeded without a collar
but fits right one gentleman wear the
lapel it's sort of you know like that I
don't believe that's messed up I believe
he did that on purpose a little kind of
suave
I like that for two reasons one it's not
about don't look at my neck and for two
it gives them a little bit of flair it
takes away from from here if there's
ruffles these days maybe the collar open
without a tie is kind of cool too I like
that these guys have their shirts tucked
in don't don't don't
unlucky shirt black tie dress up get
dressed if you want to go barefoot no
not cool either studs I don't know it's
nice to have the clean white pearl
buttons it's nice to have studs again I
don't think they should be louder than
your than your tuxedo
[Music]
black tie I'm gonna talk about black tie
optional you wear a tie I don't care if
it's green I don't care if it's yellow I
don't care if the bolo I want something
around the neck for you to say it's a
tie whatever it is I don't care let it
be
when I see likitha Satan good the
stylists not know how to tie the bow tie
did he not know how to tie the bow tie
or does he just not give it and it's
there I think of an open tie as after
the wedding after the bar mitzvah you're
on the way home from dinner you're
feeling good you might have a cigarette
in the drink and you didn't realize you
left the club I don't care because he's
wearing it with confidence I like how
he's wearing tails it's borrowed from
back in the day Edwardian times I
believe when they when they wore the
tails this is a chalk striped tail in
black and white
silky and it looks killer I think
there's a few bows a man can wear a
[ __ ] vote or vote I guess if you skate
it's a tie ball around your waist
now with the shoelace I love a pre-tied
bow tie only when it's sort of Lanvin
tom for big big big velvet and I say
that because you can't tie them it's
almost impossible to tie that into a bow
tie but generally I don't want to see a
pre-tied bow tie I love a neck tie with
a tuxedo on that note it says kind of
like you know I'm not trying too fussy
with a bow tie and it's it's still
traditional I don't want to see a tie
when it should be in place to the boat I
want to see a tie when it works really
well with the suit and I think that's
either when the guy wears a black suit
instead of a tuxedo and it passes as
cocido
I like a tie when it's not a shawl
collar and I like a tie when it's
double-breasted if you're gonna go
clip-on tie don't leave that gap there
fill it up they've got adjusters make it
tight make it fitted I never show that
if you're sweating a little bit you're a
little bit hot you want to slightly
loosen it that's my rule and then pick
it right back up so the button is open
whether you're still filling that gap no
one knows that I'm breathing right now
but it's not dangling I don't like that
space right there that's just not right
seeing a trend of a lot of doodads I
don't love it I don't know that it took
seal needs anything more than a flower a
boutonniere I don't think he needs
sparkle here and you definitely don't
need sparkle on both lapels I don't
think men should wear timepieces when
wearing formal attire
you should have nowhere else to be but
where you are I think it's so look at me
I think they're these rules of like
where else do you have to be and that's
why you don't need to watch it a formal
affair but today I think it seemed worse
because there it's like these giant
timepieces that take away from
everything else whether it's black
midnight blue Navy Brown doesn't matter
I'm seeing a trend I don't really love
in evening wear where it's sockless
there's a special hosiery for Black Tie
and it's a very very fine fine fine fine
sock doesn't have to be from France but
it's a fine fine sock I love a red sock
black tie because it's given little pop
actually a little purple or any shade of
lavender lilac sugar for another pop of
color but but sockless is a little weird
to me
if the trouser meets the shoe forget how
low it meets the show but if it meets
the shoe we don't have to see your fun
socks look at me socks your go to hell
socks you sucks we don't need to see it
and that's great but the minute it's
cropped at all there's that pop of red
that's not a pop anymore when I say a
pop of red I mean if you cross your legs
there it is it's not when you're
standing up there it is it should be
subtle these are things for you for
those that are near and dear to you
they're they're subtleties in the way of
shoes I guess there's evening pumps
which we're not seeing that much more
modern evening pump which I actually
love is the Belgian loafer the Belgian
shoe is a great boat it's a vow that's
barely there I love the Belgian for
black tie I think it's a do-it-all shoe
actually I think it works with shorts
and a t-shirt I think it works really
well black tie sneakers I think is a
no-go when we're talking classic tux and
it's tricky you know most guys they
don't have a tuxedo so they're either
borrowing one renting one getting one
last minute I might never wear this
again so I don't want to buy $450
English bench made shoes guess what you
need
you don't have to be patent-leather they
can be brogues that could be wingtips
but it shouldn't be a penny loafer and
it shouldn't be a beat-up shoe there's
something really really elegant about
wearing a white tuxedo jacket with black
pants you gotta be really really careful
you can't rub up against the cake you
can't hug up on people with makeup you
really got it
stand your own and white and it also
it's very stand out when people are
wearing black tie and you're in white
really stands out I love how Cassidy
wore the hat with it you know black tie
with a hat it's not easy it's not easy
Cassidy generally his hats I don't want
to say they're wearing him but they're
loud they're out there and I like the
sort of anti fit jacket and I'm curious
if it was created like that or not it's
sort of like a waiter at the Palms
restaurant and I don't mean that in a
bad way it's sort of like a one size
fits most jacket I like how it's with
ballet slippers velvet slippers I like
that you actually can't see the
shirt-cuff coming out it's kind of
breaking a bunch of rules I like what I
like most actually it's how the bowtie
goes the collar to collar it's filling
up the whole gap there's no pee-wee
Herman reference there's no clown
reference it's actually just perfect the
navy tux is a beautiful thing it keeps
it interesting in a sea of black when
sure where anytime where there's not a
lot of black tuxedos in general out
there and these war ceremonies but Navy
keeps it fresh and it makes you look
twice oh he's not wearing black he's
daring and it's still conservative it
still kind of blends in and it still
it's still really dark black tie and
black shoes with navy is so beautiful
when we went from black tie to a lot of
midnight blues and weird shades of blue
after that I think the next step was
just colors pinks and mobs and natural
and all kinds of you know ice blue and
all colors in the tuxedo and at a time
when men don't own pink and women don't
own blue and you know every colors for
everyone in fabrics are for everyone
silhouettes are for everyone I would
like to see more colorful tuxedos but I
think when you're going color that's
when you have to go more classic with
the fit the shine should be shiny but
not too much Sheen a little bit of a
sheen is great a lot of a sheen I think
is just too much in any light
indoor-outdoor prom carpet I think it's
just a lot to see a brown tuxedo or
a black shawl collar and silk with it
with a brown tuxedo that's a beautiful
beautiful combination if it's a dark
dark dark brown tuxedo on the money one
thing I really would love to see with a
brown tuxedo is a black tie I love the
contrast even if the lapel is not black
and the whole tuxedo is brown I still
love the contrast of black tie keeping
it black I like that with navy I almost
like that with any color succeed Oh
velvet I see a lot of velvet tuxedos and
I wonder how hot they must be it seems
like they're in the warmer months and
they're still wearing velvet that tries
me crazy but if they're comfortable in
the air conditioning is pumping in there
by all means go for it velvet shows it's
where a lot more kind of like a moleskin
kind of like the suit I'm wearing after
you know a half hour or sometimes
sitting there walking getting out of the
car it shows it's where so that's one
thing you have to be really careful
about with velvet you don't want to walk
like this and crispy but at the same
time that better be nice cotton velvet
or Velvets sateen where it wears nicely
if money is no object I think that's the
term you know you can spend anything on
your on your tuxedo I'd go to maybe Paul
Stewart in the United States maybe
terminal and Asshur in England and I say
that because when you go to these
establishments and these stores to me
our establishments they've been around
for a while they're not pop ups by any
means they've been doing this for a long
time you know Turnbull and probably Paul
Stewart they have rooms in the store for
even where you sit down in a plush chair
you know in your own dressing room and
and you get fitted in and you feel like
a king and you might even walk out with
not just a tuxedo but a smoking jacket